with the official press premiere of
spider-man no way home come and gone the
tangled web that is social media is
already rife with enough spoilers to
have fans crying spider-man no more that
being said there's no denying that the
early critical response to tom holland's
third solo outing as the iconic slinger
could set a precedent for the reaction
to the most eagerly anticipated film of
the year following the endless rumors
theories and web shots in the dark and
to just how peter parker's dimension
jumping adventure will impact the mcu
critics have given their final say on
the closing to the spider-man home
trilogy as we all hoped it's enough to
get our senses spider or otherwise well
and truly tingling while rotten tomatoes
has only accumulated just over 60
reviews for the film as of the making of
this video it's enough of a beaming
consensus to have no way home hovering
around 98 fresh if the ranking stays as
is it'll be the best reviewed entry in
holland's term as the wall crawler to
date taking the lead ahead of spider-man
homecoming at 92 percent and well ahead
of the last sequel spider-man far from
home at 90 percent so what is it that
puts no way home apart from what came
before well as the cryptic critiques for
some reviews suggest it's that it pays
respect to the past while paving the way
for the future the daily beast described
no way home as quote the finest wall
crawling mcu effort to date whereas
deadline wrote it does what the best
movies always do they thrill you and
move you and make you want to cheer in a
crowded theater it's something that
comes as no surprise given that the
closest film to a built this level of
hype was avengers end game which upon
release was followed by live reactions
to the iconic portal scene no way home
sounds like it's certainly going to
follow suit with the mary sue saying no
way home understands spider-man fans
like no other spider-man film before it
in relation to those previous films
there are of course enemies that make a
comeback in no way home thankfully it's
a guest list that director john watts
appears to have handled just right the
verge insured fans each villain gets his
moment in the sun some briefer than
others and longtime spider-man fans will
get a thrill of getting to see doc ock
smash his way through a highway of cars
a devilishly grinning green goblin
cackling his way from scene to scene or
jamie foxx's electro not having to be a
blue cgi doctor manhattan knockoff that
being said this prey still comes with a
few issues and what sounds like a near
perfect comic book movie one that still
gets caught in a web of hero issues
oh no
no
[Music]
as much as spidey's latest effort
appears to be a spectacular one no way
home doesn't look to be without a few
minor issues namely the heavy dose of
fan service and familiar issues that
come with comic book outings the
hollywood reporter described it as quote
catnip for hardcore spidey heads but
less fun than its predecessors the film
also earned a relatively positive review
from ign but the popular outlet also
dinged the spidey threqual writing the
specific fallout from certain choices
made by our friendly neighborhood
spider-man will undoubtedly see
resolution in later films but for now
they're annoying of course one thing
that most of the reviews are dodging
around is major spoilers for a film
that's been mostly kept secret multiple
spider-man appearances or not one
unanimous bit of praise falls on this
era's current spider-man and the role
that he's made his own cbr said the film
is sure to remind audiences why our
friendly neighborhood spider-man remains
one of marvel's best and that is thanks
in large part to tom holland's
performance as peter parker vanity fair
also praised the actor whose return to
the role remains uncertain after this
outing holland has built a legacy that
will long linger in the spider-man
firmament it's amazing to think that
after all this anticipation the film
seems to be living up to expectations
we'll finally see what all the fuss is
about when spidey's biggest and
potentially best adventure finally hits
our screens in epic superhero fashion on
december 17th
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you